[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في برنامج من المصدر الذي نربط
فيه خيوط القصص الاخباريه قصه اليوم هي
قصه العربيه في ذكرى تاسيسها العشرين لذلك
نخصص هذه الحلقه بالكامل لعيد ميلادها
العشرين
قناه العربيه تدخل عامها العشرين وتبقى
مصدرا بارزا للاخبار حول العالم نستعرض
ابرزها
العربيه ادخلت على المشهد الاعلامي العربي
سرديه مختلفه للخبر بعيدا عن الخطاب
الشعبوي
وفي فقره وجوه اعلاميه ريما مكتب ارتبط
اسمها بالعربيه على مدى سنوات من خطوط
المواجهه الى الاستوديو فالحوارات
[موسيقى]
20 عاما على انطلاق العربيه بشعار واحد لم
يفارقها ان تعرف اكثر الشعار لم ياتي سهوا
بل صيغه بدقه ماشيه مع توجه القناه بان
تشكل مصدرا للمعرفه والمعلومه وليست قناه
لنقل الاراء وعلى مدار عقدين ارتبط اسم
العربيه باخبار حصريه اعادت كبرى المؤسسات
الاعلاميه العالميه بثها نقلا عن العربيه
وذلك في مراحل سياسيه وامنيه مفصليه في
العالم العربي والبدايه كانت مع الغزو
الامريكي للعراق وسقوط بغداد عام 2003
المشاهد العربي الذي شهد على حرب الخليج
الاولى عبر كان طواقا لمعرفه تطور الاحداث
ولكن ليس من المنظور الامريكي هذه المره
فظهرت قناه العربيه الفتيه في ذلك الوقت
بعمر الشهرين لتنبى احتياج المشاهد العربي
لمعرفه التطورات بعيدا عن الخطاب الامريكي
الذي كان يبرر الحرب
دخلت العربيه الميدان العراقي بشبكه
مراسلين ومفادين وطواقم العمل انتشروا في
اكثر الاماكن سخونه لنقل المباشر فتميزت
العربيه بصور حصريه وتقارير شامله لتغطيه
الحدث ما اجبر العديد من المحطات
الاوروبيه الرئيسيه الى نقل التقارير
المصوره لسير المعارك عن قناه العربيه
ورغم الفوضى السياسيه والامنيه التي
اعاقبت الغزو استمرت العربيه في تغطيتها
لتسبق القنوات العالميه في بعض الاحيان
نرى هنا تنقل خبرا عن العربيه عن تبادل
الاسرى بين جماعه مقتدى الصدر والمرجعيه
الشيعيه على السيستاني
تلاحقت الاحداث في العراق ولكن في الرابع
عشر من فبراير 2005 انتقلت وجهه العناوين
الى لبنان مع نبا اختيار رئيس الحكومه
الاسبق رفيق الحريري وكانت العربيه اول من
ذاع الخبر في العالم
شاهدينا الكرام وردنا قبل قليل ان رئيس
الوزراء اللبناني السابق رفيق الحريري قد
قضى في هذا الانفجار
هذا السبق الصحفي على قساوته بالنسبه
للمشاهد العربي تقول مذيعه العربيه سوما
جابر وقتها والتي كانت اول من بث الخبر
انها ترددت في اذاعته قبل ان يدخل مدير
عام القناه وقتها بنفسه الى غرفه التحكم
ويؤكد لها الامر لبثه فورا
التدقيق بالمعلومات قبل بثها لم ينقف
القناه متابعه الاخبار العاجله الصادره من
لبنان وعرضها لتشكل مصدرا للقنوات
العالميه وفي مساء الاحد في السابع
والعشرين من مارس 2005 بثت العربيه صور
فيديو كاميرات المراقبه القريبه من وقوع
الانفجار والتي اعتمد عليها التحقيق
الامامي للكشف عن السياره التي تم تفخيخها
صور مستندات اليها كبد الوسائل الاعلاميه
العالميه ومن ضمنها سي ان ان كما نرى هنا
واستمرت العربيه في كشف المعلومات حول
اغتيال الحريري عبر التحقيقات والمقابلات
من بينها المقابله مع نائب الرئيس السوري
عبد الحليم خدام خدام كشف عبر العربيه
تهديد الرئيس السوري المباشر للحريري قبل
اشهر من اغتياله كانت قد بثت ليله راس
السنه عام 2006
توالت التغطيات الحصريه والمقابلات المهمه
مع زعماء العالم اول رئيس امريكي من اصول
افريقيه ومسلمه اختار العربيه لظهوره
الاول اعلاميا بعد انتخابه تكلم عن خطته
للسلام في الشرق الاوسط عبر العربيه
لتشتاح المقابله كبرى الوكالات الانباء
العالميه
وبعدها انشغلت العربيه بتغطيه الثورات في
العالم العربي وكان للعربيه السقف اكثر من
مكان ولعل الابرز مداخله الرئيس المصري
الاسبق محمد حسني مبارك في العاشر من
ابريل 2011 عبر العربيه عقب رحيله عن
الحكم في مصر اقلتها ايضا كبر المؤسسات
الدوليه
وبالتزامن كانت الاعتداءات الايرانيه على
المنطقه تتصاعد وكان للعربيه معلوماتها
الحصريه التي نقلتها الوكالات عنها
كتطورات الهجوم على ارامكو وغيرها من
الاعتداءات على المنطقه وكيفيه التصدي لها
هجمات الحوثي على الملاحه الدوليه ايضا
كان لنا الصدق فيها وشكلت مصدرا للوكالات
في صيف 2021 توجهت انظار العالم نحو
افغانستان مع الانسحاب الامريكي منها
والانهيار السريع لحكومه الافغانيه على
الاتحاد ومع سقوط البلاد في قبضه طالبان
العربيه كانت الطبقه الوكالات الدوليه
واجره حوارا مع القيادي البارز ضد حركه
طالبان الافغانيه احمد مسعود في ولايه
الافغانيه
صناع القرار في العالم التقطتهم العربيه
وحديثهم تصدر العناوين كحديث ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الذي اعلن
خلال اللقاء عن رؤيته 20 30 واستمرت
العربيه في قياده المشهد الاعلامي
الاخباري السياسي وبقي صناع القرار
يختارون قناتي العربيه والحدث لكي يوصلوا
كلمتهم كالرئيس الاوكراني فلودي الذي توجه
الى العرب بلقائه مع العربيه بعيدا اندلاع
الحربي في بلده كما
ظهر رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على شاشه
العربيه وهو المقل في اطلالاته والقائمه
تطول من القاده العالميين الذين لا زالوا
يختارون العربيه للوصول الى اكبر عدد من
المشاهدين
اينما وجد الحدث وجدت العربيه لنقل
المعلومه الدقيقه والصوره المباشره
للمشاهدين فكنا موجودين عندما عبرت
الدبابات الروسيه الاولى الحدود مع
اوكرانيا زميلتنا كريستيان بيصري كانت
هناك لمواكبه الحدث الذي كان العالم يرتقب
حدوثه مع تصاعد حده التوتر بين الجانبين
بعض الفاصل موسيقى العربيه التي طبعت
اذهان مشاهديها على مدى عقدين ما قصتها
بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قناه العربيه شرح اكتسب
قيمته بسبب محتواه الذي ادخل خطابا مختلفا
عن المشهد الاعلامي العربي هذا بعدما بقي
الاعلام لسنوات رهينه دعايه التطرف
والتحريض حتى في ذروه احداث الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر التي كانت تستدعي تغييرا في الوعي
العربي الجمعي رسم خريطه جديده للصحافه في
الشرق الاوسط عنوان تقرير نيويورك تايمز
على العربيه صدر في عام 2004 وقد يلخصوه
هويه المحطه هويه تستند الى تقديم
المعلومه وطرح جديد اكثر موضوعيه بعيدا عن
الخطاب الشعبوي الذي تغذى على نشر التطرف
والتشدد ونبذل اخر بغطاء ديني او وطني ما
سمى ما افكار اجيال من الشباب ودفعهم
فئاتون الارهاب
[موسيقى]
تغطيه حرب العراق كانت اول امتحان لنهجه
العربيه فمع انتشار الاعمال الارهابيه
والفوضى كانت التنظيمات تتسابق على تبني
التفجيرات على انها اعمال وطنيه ضد الغزو
الامريكي للعراق وهي في الواقع لم تكن في
كثير من الاحيان الا مجرد منافسه على
النفود بين بعضها البعض سواء كانت تنظيمات
سنيه او شيعيه كانت العربيه تسمي الاشياء
بمسمياتها وتصف اعمال العنف باعمال
الارهابيه حينما تستهدف المدنيين معرضا
طاقمه العربيه الى الكثير من التهديدات
وعمليات الاستهداف راح ضحيتها احد عشر من
كوادرها خلال الحرب على العراق
المعركه ضد دعايه الارهاب لم تقتصر على
العراق في لبنان استعرت معركه بين الجيش
اللبناني ومتطرفي تنظيم فتح الاسلام
التابع للقاعده في مخيم نهر البارد شمال
لبنان في عام 2007 واثناء عمليه الجيش
اللبناني للقضاء على عناصر القاعده عارض
زعيم حزب الله حسن نصر الله جهود السلطات
الامنيه اللبنانيه مالفه انتباه كثيرين
تتبعت العربيه القصه حتى كشفت من خلال
وثائقي وجوه القاعده في ايران كشفت فيرارا
قيادات فتح الاسلام وعلى راسهم صالح
القرعاوي الى ايران باستخدام جوازات سفر
مزوره ومكتوا فيها حتى عام 2009
بتشابك الارهاب بين القاعده وايران و
وكلائها
انتهت معركه نهر البارد بالقضاء على
الارهابيين فيما بقي الضغط قويا على تنظيم
اخر في لبنان حزب الله فاستغنى الحزب عن
حربه ضد الدوله بالوكاله عبر تنظيمات اخرى
كفتح الاسلام وتحرك بنفسه في عام 2008
ليكشف وجهه الحقيقي لاول مره العربيه كانت
اول من سمت احداث سبعه ايام من قلاب حزب
الله فاتبين فعلا ان هذه الاحداث ليست
عمليه عسكريه عابره ضد قرارات حكوميه فمنذ
ذلك التاريخ انقلب الميزان السياسي لصالح
حزب الله واسقطت ورقه المقاومه التي تغطى
بها الحزب على مدى عقود مع خروج جحافل
الحزب من مربعاتها الامنيه في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه لتنفيذ سلسله اعتداءات على
الاهالي والمرافق الاقتصاديه والخدماتيه
روايه المتطرفين سواء من السنه او الشيعه
الذين يتغطون بشعارات زائفه تابعتها
العربيه في كل مكان حتى الى جنوب الفلبين
مراسل العربيه بكر العطيان تعرض على اثرها
الى الخطف من قبل جماعه ابو سياف لمده 18
شهرا في 2014
ظهر التنظيم الذي اطلق على نفسه اسم
الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق والشام لاسباب
عده من بينها كما يرى تيار من العراقيين
انه جاء كانت فعل على ممارسات رئيس
الوزراء العراقي وقتها نور المالك ضد
اهالي الانبار والموصل اي المناطق ذات
الغالبيه السنيه في البدء لاقت تنظيم
تعاطفا قبل ان يكشف وجهه الحقيقي ولكن منذ
اللحظه الاولى اطلقت العربيه اسم داعش على
التنظيم وليس الدوله الاسلاميه وهذا الاسم
الذي اعتمد لاحقا في جميع المؤسسات
الاعلاميه
العربيه تتبعت مواضيع الارهاب بعمق وخاصه
مع تداخل ارهاب القاعده مع ارهاب
التنظيمات التابعه لايران رغم العداوه
الظاهره بينهما حيث كشف وثائقي من اعداد
الزميل سيد الحديدي عن قائمه قيادات من
القاعده استضافتهم ايران لحمايتهم بعد
تجديد القناق عليهم الوثائقي بعنوان وجوه
القاعده في ايران ابرزهم كان ابو مصعب
الزرقاوي وسيف العدل وابو الخير المصري
وابو محمد المصري وصالح القرعاوي وذلك
العشرات من عناصر التنظيم الذين اوتهم
طهران مع اسرهم بعد هروبهم من افغانستان
كما كشف الوثائقي تفاصيل اول اجتماع سري
تم الترتيب له في السودان بين زعيم تنظيم
القاعده اسامه بن لادن وقائد فيلق القدس
الايراني قاسم سليماني حيث ناقش ضروره
تنحيه الخلافات المذهبيه وتدريب عناصر
القاعده على صناعه المتفجرات تحت اشراف
حزب الله
محاربه دعايه الارهاب هو نهج عام للمحطه
التي خصصت له برنامجا خاصا لاقى نجاحا
كبيرا بسبب دخوله الى مناطق امنيه خطيره
لصبر اغوار التطرف عبد الله بن مجاد مؤسس
ومعد برنامج صناعه الموت نستضيفه في هذه
الحلقه الخاصه الذي كافح الاخبار المضلله
والخطاب التعبوي خلال مسيرته المهنيه
صناعه الموت اول برنامج متخصص بالارهاب
اسم قوي لبرنامج متميز هل لك ان تشرح لنا
حيثيات تاسيس هذا البرنامج وفي اي مرحله
سياسيه انطلق من خلالها برنامج صناعه
الموت كانت الفكره ان هذا الجانب الذي هو
جانب الارهاب اصبح اولويه للسياسه الدوليه
وبالذات بعد احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
والمعنيون به الاكثر هم المسلمون والعرب
لانه ينطلق من خلفيه عربيه وخلفيه مسلمه
فنحن اولى الناس بمكافحه
خطاب الارهاب وجماعات الارهاب وتنظيمات
الارهاب والحمد لله يعني نجح البرنامج
وسجل نسب مشاهده عاليه وسجل تاثير كبير
لدى المشاهدين
التخيل الذي نشهده الان في السعوديه هل
يمكن قول ان الافكار التطرف وهذا الخطاب
التعبوي خف وبالتالي
مكافحه تلك الافكار خفت
نعم ما في شك الارهاب كعمل ارهابي وعمل
اجرامي ومباشر خف بسبب قوه القبضه الامنيه
وبسبب الرؤيه السياسيه الشامله لتطوير
البلد والمجتمع والدوله والحكومه
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبالتالي
فمنسوب الارهاب المباشر خف ايضا في ضرب
التيارات الاصوليه المتطرفه التي تمهد
للارهاب تشريعيا وقانونيا فبالتالي خف
ولكنه لم ينتهي ولا يمكن ان ينتهي يعني
بسرعه هذا منطقه تاريخ وطبيعه الاشياء
والجماعات وطبيعه الافكار والمفاهيم انها
لا تنتهي وبالتالي لا زالت المعركه مستمره
وان كانت الحاجه الى التتبع المباشر قد
خفت بناء على التطورات التي حدثت سياسيا
واجتماعيا وغيرها
عربيه بعد الاختناق من ثقافه التطرف هل لك
ان تشرح تلك النقطه بالذات نعم كان
الارهاب يتصاعد منذ منتصف التسعينات
تقريبا ثم انتشر
انتشار النار في الهشيم فلما جاء كانت
الخطابات الاعلاميه المنتشره والمتفشره في
تلك المرحله
تدعم الارهاب وتعبويه بمعنى انها تعبئ
المشاهد
بالغضب بالحماس بالاستفزاز وكان خطاب
الاصوليه والارهاب خطاب متمكن في تغطيه
الاحداث والاخبار والاراء فلما جاءت
العربيه كانت الرؤيه
في تلك المرحله ان تكون خطابا معرفيا او
خطابا اخباريا مباشرا بمعنى انه يعنى
بالمعرفه ان تعرف اكثر كما هو شعار
العربيه بعيدا عن الخطابات التعبويه التي
تتحدث عن الاراء وعن الخطابات وعن الارهاب
وعن التسويق والترويج للخطابات الارهاب
وقياداته فشكلت حقيقه شكلت لحظه فارقه في
التغطيات الاعلاميه ومن ضمنها كان برنامج
صناعه الموت لشرح كل هذه التفاعل الابعاد
والتفاصيل لكل المشاهدين عبد الله بن مجاد
الكاتب السعودي شكرا جزيلا لك
في فقره الوجه الاعلامي لهذا الاسبوع
اخترنا رمى مكتبي التي ارتبط اسمها
بالعربيه رغم خوضها تجارب اعلاميه مختلفه
هي التي عملت في معظم الاقسام في العربيه
من مراسله حرب الى مذيعه رئيسيه وخلف
الكواليس ايضا كمديره مكتب العربيه في
لندن تجربه غنيه تميزت خلالها في كل
المحطات منذ التغطيتها لحرب تموز في لبنان
الى تغطيتها لحرب اوكرانيا من خلال حوارات
مع شخصيات مؤثره في بريطانيا اهلا بك ريما
اهلا جيلان شكرا للاستضافه يطلق عليك في
المحطه نجمه نجمه شامله او صحفيه شامله
وعملت في مختلف المجالات داخل المحطه داخل
العربيه اين تجدين نفسك اكثر
يعني انا بلاقي حاله دائما
بالاحداث الكبيره يكون على الارض قريبه من
الخبر
خاصه اذا كان حروب او اذا كان ازمات كبيره
دائما تفضل الميدان لكن ايضا الحوارات
المهمه وجلسات الحواريه اللي بنقدر ناخذ
فيها بعض الحقائق
والمعلومات
ومواقف سياسيه مهمه انا بامن انه الاعلام
هو جزء من التغيير في العالم العربي
ما هي ابرز
موقف او محطه مهنيه تستوقفك او ما زالت
تستوقفك حتى الان تغطيه حرب تموز لا شك ان
هي وضعتني على خارطه الاعلام الحربي
التغطيه الميدان وايضا مراسله الحروب
عملت فرق كتير كبير بحياه المهنيه
وكانت من اصعب المهمات طبعا
على مدى عشتينا عاما ماذا تركت العربيه
اثرا فيك مهنيا
20 عام العربيه اخذت احلى سنين عمري
اعطيتها احلى سنين عمري
واعطتني كثير اعطتني تجربه مهنيه كثير
غنيه اعطتني كرير يعني
[موسيقى]
حياه مهنيه حلوه انا بفتخر فيها وانا
اعطيتها احلى سنين عمري اعطيتها من قلبي
عطيتها بكثير شغف
ولازلنا مستمرين ماذا علمتك يعني مهنيا
في الصحافه الميدانيه
الحوارات
السياسيين بحاولوا يتهربوا من الاجابات
الصريحه ونحن بنحاول ناخذ منهم اجابات
مهمه علمتني تواضع علمتني التفانه علمتني
الاحتراف
علمتني حب حب الاعلام والبحث عن الحقيقه
علمتني انه نحن جزء من التغيير بالعالم
العربي تغيير الى الافضل الجيل الجديد من
الصحفيين ماذا تقولين لهم بالنسبه للعربيه
بقول لهم نحن هون لنساعدكن اي شيء
بتحتاجوه كتير شرف كبير لالنا انه نمد ايد
المساعده لانه صعب بهالمه انه يجي انسان
او صحافه او صحافه
بقول لهم انه كونوا
صادقين بعطائكم لهالمهنه بما معنى انه
هيدي الشاشه مش للنجوميه هذا الشاشه
لتغطيه الخبر الاحداث نحن موجودين لنغطي
الحدث مش لنكون نحن الحدث وبقول لهم انه
مع الشغف للتغطيه الميدانيه
انتبهوا انه انتم تبقوا شاهدين على
الحقيقه وعلى الاحداث وما تكونوا انتم
الهدف
الشجاعه انه تبقوا على قيد الحياه وتغطوا
الاخبار مش انه تصيروا شهداء الحقيقه
وشهداء الاخبار والتغطيه وبتمنى سلامه
للجميع والنجاح للجميع حصلت على جوائز
عديده اخرها ربما جائزه الابداع الاعلامي
برايك ما الذي ميزك منذ انطلاقتك في
المجال الاعلامي بعتقد اني اعطيت هالمهنه
كل شيء
كل شيء بحياتي
ضحيت فيها بحياتي الشخصيه من وقت عائلتي
من وقت حياتي الشخصيه اعطيتك كل شغفه وكل
حياتي
بعتقد مشان هيك احيانا
بيتم ملاحظه عملنا
انا شاكره لاي جائزه باخدها بس بفتكر
الجائزه الاكبر اللي بنخدها هو
متابعه المشاهدين وفاءن لالنا
وايمانهم فينا
وتصديق الخبر اللي بنقوله المصداقيه اخر
سؤال الفرق بين عملك تي سي ان ان كمحطه
عالميه والمحطه العربيه المحطه الب كنت
فاكر انه نحن بالاعلام العربي السقف
السياسي مش كثير مرتفع وعنا كثير محازير
تجربه كانت تجربه غنيه كثير وانا فخوره
فيها ولكن علمتني كمان انه الاعلام
الاجنبي والغربه او الاعلام عنده محاذير
وكمان وعندهم الرقابه اللي بتخص فيهم
مختلفه عن الاعلام العربي
احيانا في مواضيع السقف السياسي او الخط
التحريري فيها مش حريه اكثر بس في امور
ثانيه لا ونفس الشيء بالنسبه للاعلام
العربي
تعلمت المهنيه والاحتراف لكن بشد عقيد كل
صحفي عربي بمحطات عربيه كل يوم عم بحاول
انه
يغطي الخبر بمهنيه ومصداقيه وبهامش من
الحريه ما حدا احسن من حدا نعم ريما مكتبي
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
تعرفون سر الموسيقى التي ارتبطت في وجدان
محبي ومتابعي اخبار العربيه قصتها تتلخص
في التالي اداره القناه ارادت منذ
انطلاقتها ان تكون الموسيقى المرافقه
لنشرات الاخبار عابره للثقافات وليست
مرتبطه بمنطقه ماء وبلد ما فابتعدت عن
الموسيقى المعتمده على الدرامز والتي
تستخدم عاده في القنوات الامريكيه كما لم
تكن تريد ان يتضمن اللحن الات موسيقيه
اشتهرت في المنطقه العربيه والاقليميه
كالعود مثلا فمن بين لائحه من الالحان بقي
هذا اللحن عالقا في ذهن القيمين على
المحطه ومتابعيها حول العالم
[موسيقى]
ومع فقره اخبار الاعلام السريعه تستمر
قناه العربيه في ريادتها ونجاحها حيث حققت
القناه المرتبه الاولى في عدد متابعيها
على مواقع التواصل لشهر فبراير 2023 تلتها
قناه الحدث
وبهذا نصل الى نهايه حلقتنا لليوم والتي
خصصناها للذكرى العشرين لانطلاق قناه
العربيه موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل شكرا
لحسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]